when we're talking about major Wars in
colonial North America we tend to think
about the American Revolution not its
earlier iteration the Seven Years War
and I think that's a shame because the
Seven Years War was incredibly
influential not only on the American
Revolution but on the complexion of the
world thanks to the Seven Years War
Canada became a British country not a
French country
the Acadians moved down to Louisiana and
became known as the Cajuns and most
importantly England became the world's
pre-eminent empire so if you've been
following along this far you may have
noticed two things one that the people
who named this war seemed to be very bad
at math because 1754 to 1763 is nine
years not seven and that this war seems
to have two names both the Seven Years
War and the French and Indian War which
is a name you perhaps have heard before
well let me tackle those two oddities in
reverse order so not only does the Seven
Years War have two names it has a whole
number of names it's called the Seven
Years War the French and Indian War the
war of the conquest the pomeranian war
the third Silesian war the third
Carnatic war this is a war with a whole
bunch of names and the reason that it
has a whole bunch of names is that it
was fought in a whole bunch of places
the Seven Years War was really the first
global war and we're talking a hundred
and fifty years before World War one
aspects of the Seven Years War as you
can kind of see from this map were
fought in Europe in South America the
coast of Africa in India the Philippines
and of course in North America the many
different names come from the many
different
months of this war and I would say that
French and Indian War is actually the
name for the North American front of
this war or theater of this war so there
are two reasons why I think Seven Years
War is a better name than French and
Indian War one is that seven years war
gets at the idea that it was not just
happening in North America was happening
all over the world so it shows that it
was a global war but I also think seven
years war is a better name than French
and Indian War because I think French
and Indian War is kind of confusing
because you would think that it means
that the principal parties in this war
were the English versus the French and
the Indians when in fact it was the
English and their Indian allies versus
the French and their Indian allies
Native Americans fought on both sides of
this conflict
so rather than the English and Indian
versus French and Indian War let's go
with a shorter seven years war which
brings us back to our awkward date range
so the reason that it's called the Seven
Years War is because the English didn't
actually declare war on the French until
1756 so even though fighting started a
little bit earlier
in North America the true range of dates
at least in legal terms is from 1756 to
1763 or seven years it's a complicated
name for a complicated war but really
what it came down to was England and
France duking it out over who was going
to be the supreme imperial power in the
world and they were concerned about who
was going to have the most territory in
the world therefore their concern over
who was going to control North America
in their competing claims here and also
access to
trade so who was going to be able to
trade with North Americans who was going
to be able to trade with the lucrative
Indian subcontinent and who would be the
leading power in Europe so let's dial in
a little closer on the North American
theater of this war which will have the
most effect on the future United States
alright so here is a map of territorial
claims by European powers in North
America before the Seven Years War now
you can see that there are some places
where they overlap which is really going
to be the heart of the problem in this
conflict so England shown here in red
I'm going to outline it a bit was as you
know from your early American history
here along the eastern seaboard of
what's today the United States and also
up into Canada France claimed this
interior region of Canada and today the
territorial United States and Spain was
in the mix here
remember Spain has still been a fairly
influential colonial power in Florida
and in contemporary Mexico and also down
here in Cuba and South America alright
so we've got three major European powers
in the mix here in North America England
France and Spain but what this map
doesn't show is the American Indian
powers who are also in this area so most
of this region really west of the
Appalachian Mountains is Indian country
and the majority of Hat inhabitants were
Native Americans and they really held
the
of power in this region as well so major
Native American groups that are in play
in this conflict are Iroquois
Confederacy and also Cherokees herranz
Algonquin Abenaki z-- and Micmacs and
that's just a small sampling so you can
see that there are a number of important
Native American tribes who are
specifically in this area of Canada
which is disputed and also living in the
greater Appalachian region so what does
each of these groups want well England
definitely wants territory they want to
make sure that their English settlers
along the eastern seaboard whom we'll
soon be calling Americans have room to
expand the French want to make sure that
they still have access to trade with
Native Americans because their main
concern is fur which is a very valuable
commodity in Europe and Spain wants to
make sure that they have access to their
sugar islands and also their precious
metals in the Caribbean and in South
America now it's worth noting because
I think this is really interesting to
students of American history that all of
this territory all of North America was
way less valuable than all of this
territory because we're not talking
about just valuing land we're talking
about value in commodities and what the
Caribbean had was sugar and sugar is the
most valuable crop in this time period
so a tiny island down here in the
Bahamas is probably worth more to a
European power than the entire interior
of North America and what do these
Native American groups want well some of
them want help with revenge on each
other many other smaller Native American
groups have been displaced by the
Iroquois who are here in upstate New
York kind of Quebec region so the
Iroquois is actually expanding and
really defending their claim as the
largest Native American Empire but the
other thing that they want is to make
sure that their territory is no longer
encroached upon by English settlers in
particular now one mistake I see early
students of US history making is
thinking that all Native Americans kind
of shared a cultural and political bond
right that they saw themselves as one
larger people who had to unite against
the encroachment of Europeans and that
was definitely not the case Native
Americans had been living in this
territory for thousands of years and
they had enemies and beef with other
groups that went back way longer than
the arrival of Europeans in North
America so when nations like England and
France arrived with their weapons and
their trade goods the American Indians
didn't look at each other and say oh
wait now we're
all one race we need to join together
against the encroachment of whites they
saw England and France and Spain as
possible avenues to getting one up on
their older enemies so when an English
trader sold a gun to say a her on he was
way more likely to go after say the
Iroquois with that gun than he was to go
after a French trader so another reason
why the Seven Years War is a better name
for the French and Indian War than
French and Indian War is because these
Native American groups did not ally all
with France in fact the Iroquois and
Cherokee ended up allied with England
and most of the other Native American
groups ended up allied with France but
they were fighting each other in
addition to fighting England all right
so the stage is set for this conflict
with all of these competing groups in
this unclear territory and how this
turns into a war we'll get to you in the
next video